E aí
[Música]
Olá eu sou Cláudio minha companheira diz
que eu sou um milagre que milagre eu
entendo ela dizia isso porque
principalmente Eu escuto ela e a gente
pare a conversa eu escuto e conversa
sobre que ela tá trazendo para mim eu te
aviso com ela as tarefas do Lar então a
gente mora na mesma casa né então lavar
louça lavar roupa arrumar a casa faz
parte Vocês tem uma filha linda Maria
Luiza e eu não sou pai que ajuda não sou
pai que cuida então eu troco fralda do
banho do comida leva no parquinho é para
né Bota para dormir a gente ir de vídeo
esse desafio que é criar uma criança O
Sexo Também ela disse que eu sou
empático respeito ela e ela Vivi
experiências de bastante prazer então é
por isso que ela acha que eu sou esse
tal milagre Mas eu prefiro pensar que eu
sou mesmo é o fruto de uma transformação
vou contar para vocês um pouco da minha
história
e para vocês entenderem esse dilema é
quando nascia o meu pai dia que eu nasci
Meu pai deixou minha mãe na porta da
Maternidade nem entrou aí ele foi embora
e voltou a dois dias depois para buscar
ela e a criança não deu muita explicação
e levou a gente para casa eu lembro de
quando era criança tava em casa
brincando e aí de repente eu tô com o
telefone era ele ele falou Cláudio
pergunta para tua mãe aí se o Chico
chegou aí eu falei mãe quem é Chico Não
conheço nenhum Chicco e eu vi que a cara
dela ficou um pouco transtornado
ela foi falar com ele no telefone e só
um tempo depois que eu entendi que o que
ele queria saber se ela tinha ficado
menstruada para saber se vinha para casa
aquele dia para transar com ela ou se é
dormir na rua com outras mulheres como
Ele fez muitas vezes a Uma vez eu tava
passeando com meu pai de carro e estava
distraído Ouvindo uma música de repente
ele encostou na calçada tinha umas
mulheres ele falou ou gostosa gostosa
vem cá vamos ali no a transar comigo com
o meu filho e eu falei uai que que é
isso não sabia onde enfiar minha cara eu
morri de vergonha achei aqui no mal de
respeito com aquelas mulheres e com a
minha mãe tava em casa esperando a gente
ele fazer isso em plena luz do dia não
foram poucas as vezes que eu fiquei
constrangido na frente de mulheres por
causa dessas brincadeiras e piadas na
adequadas do meu pai a minha primeira
Experiência sexual foi no [ __ ]
para mim foi muito bom foi bem ruim
assim foi uma experiência sem sentido eu
sou um cara sensível aí para mim cheguei
lá e queria conversar com aquelas
pessoas saber da vida delas mas eu não
pude negar meu pai já vinha dizendo por
aí não é muito firme na É isso aí vai
virar [ __ ] como se ser homossexual
fosse algo ruim algo vergonhoso então
elevou no [ __ ] para ver se eu virava
o macho que ele queria que eu fosse e
olha mesmo com todas as experiências com
meu pai eu confesso que ele muito tempo
ainda foi o meu herói o pai é o nosso
herói né então eu precisei humanizar
aquela pessoa para entender que ele
também não aprendeu sozinho
entendeu essas referências com o pai
dele dizem que meu avô também era igual
do mesmo jeito agora imagina qual a
relação que eu criei com as mulheres a
partir dessas referências que eu aprendi
com o meu pai
O que é isso a gente aprende pelas é
pelos exemplos e pelas referências né
Tudo bem disso ele já Mila Ribeiro nós
homens somos constituídos para consumir
as mulheres e não para apreciá-las o
mais homens quando nascemos temos assim
como se fosse uma gente vem com manual
de instrução é com as normas que a gente
precisa fazer para ser homem uma delas é
essa que o homem tem que estar sempre
rápido sexualmente tem que comer todas
as mulheres gente tem que ser
experiente dominante com relação às
mulheres só que eu acho uma piada por
que de fato os homens não conversam
sobre isso os Homens Contam muitas
vantagens mas não falam entre si sobre
Sexo e Sexualidade a gente acaba
aprendendo o que se sabe na pornografia
tenta levar isso para a vida real e fica
muito ansioso para reproduzir aquelas
cenas dos filmes eu acho até que isso
faz com que a gente tenha a tal da
ejaculação precoce
se não nós homens o homem nessa cartilha
diz que o homem tem que aguentar o
tranco o homem tem que ser firme vamos
tem que ser mas tem que falar Grosso tem
que ter um físico né tem que ser
assertivo Não pode errar tem que ser
trabalhador tem que ser o provedor da
casa
e é muito difícil para um homem viver
numa casa onde uma mulher ganha mais que
ele se sentir um fracassado
a pior das suas pior dessas normas que
eu acho é a que diz que o homem não pode
viver as emoções não pode expressar seus
sentimentos são Liberdade com verdade
não pode mostrar sua vulnerabilidade
nós homens ainda acreditamos e Homem que
é homem não chora
e isso é muito complicado porque a gente
vai vivendo as emoções internamente e
vai virando uma pressão eterna a gente
vai virando uma panela de pressão ficar
nessa caixa apertada é algo muito
compressor a gente vai vivendo uma massa
Pergunta para um homem está tudo bem ele
vai dizer tá tudo bem mas por dentro
muitas vezes ele tá ponto de explodir e
muitas vezes ele explode explode em
atitude de violentas basta a gente ver
os números do anuário do Fórum
Brasileiro de Segurança Pública você ver
a quantidade a centenas de mulheres que
diariamente buscam as delegacias para
fazer queixas de violência doméstica a
quantidade de homicídio de mulheres a
quantidade de estupros nas ruas em
estupro marital que essa violência
silenciosa que acontece dentro das casas
diariamente
e os números são assustadores mas que eu
queria trazer aqui aqui
esse mesmo homem que mata violenta
assassina pintar o redor dele também
machuca mata é assassina assim mesmo
aqui no Brasil a campanha Setembro
Amarelo trouxe um dado impressionante
que os homens cometem suicídio até
quatro vezes mais do que as mulheres
E nós homens somos a maioria da
população carcerária a maioria da
população em situação de rua é claro que
aqui tem um recorte de raça e de classe
social mas dentro desse recorte os
homens também estão em grandes
Sofrimentos eu sou um cara Branco um
cara hétero um cara classe média tem um
pênis isso me dá uma série de vantagens
e facilidades mas um exemplo de viver
dores também nós homens somos os mais
viciados em pornografia Os mais viciados
em drogas os que consomem excessivamente
álcool as maiores vítimas de acidente de
carro porque ele sabia de Jesus causa
igual uns loucos que a gente precisa
explodir expressar essa noção de alguma
forma mas também um cara no jogo de
futebol onde ele pode ir no Dias emoção
eu sei disso porque eu vivi essas dores
eu vivi nessa caixa apertada muito tempo
eu sou fruto disso e eu cheguei numa na
minha vida adulta de uma forma que eu
já tinha uma vida que não fazia sentido
para mim eu tava trabalhando 12 horas
dentro de um escritório eu tava tendo
uma vida sexual ruim sem prazer tendo a
ejaculação precoce falta direção você
conseguir transar com a minha
companheira traindo minha companheira
indo para [ __ ] cheguei até 30 quilos
acima do meu peso eu tava sem saúde
até que chegou uma hora que eu não sei
como eu fui parar não
Retiro de meditação de respiração e ali
depois de um processo longo de
respiração eu tive uma crise de choro eu
chorei eu chorei profundamente eu chorei
como a muito tempo eu não chorava na
minha vida e ali eu via que eu tinha
chegado no fundo do posto eu falei eu
vou morrer se eu continuar assim eu vou
morrer cara
e eu não sei se você teve as mesmas
experiências que eu tive os mesmos
exemplos na sua vida mas eu acredito que
de alguma forma você deve estar
empatizando com alguma coisa que eu tô
falando aqui porque a sessão Dores dos
homens tá Cláudio Mas e aí como é que
agente faz para mudar essa realidade
como é que a gente transforma isso como
é que a gente se transforma por nesse
desses em buchas para esse cara legal
esse milagre a sua companheira falou
como é que a gente por vem uma
sexualidade mais plena feliz
e foi nessa busca no mergulho profundo
em mim mesmo na busca do meu prazer de
viver que nasceu o prazer ele e essa
iniciativa que tem a missão em apoiar os
homens essa transformação nesta
travessia para se livrar dessa caixa se
livrar desse conjunto de comportamentos
machistas que tanto nos oprimem para
ajudar os homens a viverem uma vida
sexual mais plena e feliz
eu creio um curso no prazer ele chamado
sexo sexualidade tudo que seu pai não te
ensinou
Eu acho que por isso que elas procuram
prazer ele para aprender a transar
melhor é mas eu entendi aqui antes da
gente chegar nesse tema a gente vai
precisar fazer uma jornada de retorno
para casa uma jornada de retorno para
nossa infância porque foi lá aquela
criança que se perdeu das suas emoções
se perdeu nessas normas e regras e aí é
muito bonito poder ver esses homens
adultos
deixando cair em suas máscaras e
derretendo essa geleira acho que
separavam eles da sua verdade e
perceberem cara que tem outros caras que
estão no mesmo barco furado você não
está sozinho cara essa resgate da
infância que a gente vai perceber também
como começou a nossa relação com a nossa
sexualidade
essa experiência da individualidade como
é que eu comecei a conhecer meu corpo
onde eu tenho prazer na minha perna no
meu pé na minha orelha como é que eu
gosto
Oi e a partir desse momento nesse estado
de vulnerabilidade de bastante diálogo
reflexão no espaço seguro que a gente
começa a falar sobre sexo e aí eu vou te
falar cara como os homens estão
transando mal gente os homens hetero
então não conhecem seus corpos não
conhece o corte de suas parcerias entre
a gente entra nessa lógica maluca da
pornografia e acha que só o pau transa e
a gente esquece que tem uns todo um
corpo para sentir prazer você potente
já escutei relatos de cara que fizeram
meu curso quando tava na intimidade com
suas parceiras escutaram Obrigado code
porque tava vivendo uma experiência
muito mais prazerosa eu tava tendo um
orgasmo que o cara tava ali conectado
uma forma mais real
e a gente deve isso para ela mas eu
acredito que a gente também deve isso
para gente mesmo Todo mundo merece ter
uma vida mais leve plena feliz o mundo
merece viver uma sexualidade mais
potente e positivo e você tá a fim de
dar esse passo de volta para casa tá
afim de ir além do que a sociedade te
disse que você precisava ser para ser
homem tá a fim de além do que seu pai te
ensinou sobre Sexo e Sexualidade A Hora
é Agora
E aí
[Música]